un inicio de año complicado en portugal
presidencia de la unión europea y este
domingo elecciones a la jefatura de
estado en plena tercera ola con récords
de fallecidos confinamiento y escuelas
cerradas
deberíamos posponer estas elecciones
para mejores días no tiene sentido una
suspensión que se estudio y se descartó
expertos esperan un mínimo histórico de
participación así que para incentivar
los comicios carteles en el metro que
aseguran que votar es seguro un mensaje
que también quiere trasladar el actual
presidente y favorito a la reválida el
socialdemócrata marcelo reveló de souza
es muy importante decirle a los
portugueses que las elecciones existen y
que la democracia no está suspendida por
eso cambie mi decisión inicial de no
hacer campaña en las calles por la
pandemia
el actual presidente se enfrenta a otros
seis aspirantes y parte con una clara
mayoría por lo que el resultado podría
quedar definido en primera vuelta sin
embargo mucho se ha hablado de un rival
que está ganando cada vez más fuerza
andrew aventura del partido de extrema
derecha basta y apoyado por marine lepén
como se sabe queremos otro sistema
queremos romper con la constitución y
nos vamos a encargar de ello
para hacer posible la votación portugal
ha permitido que unas 200.000 personas
de los alrededor de 10 millones de
votantes registrados hayan votado
anticipadamente